au québec il ya beaucoup moins
d'anglophones en proportion dans la
population
quand on est à l'extérieur de la région
de montréal et le gouvernement du québec
à une préoccupation pour ces communautés
l' exode en train de plus en plus les
flics mans de cette communauté doit s
que le nombre d'anglophones en dehors de
montréal diminue est ce qu'ils sont
capables d'avoir des services dans leur
langue
on a baissé
en fait lorsque le gouvernement du
québec évoque des chiffres ce sont des
données de 2006 selon les données les
plus récentes
en 1996 il y avait 173 milles québécois
à l'extérieur de montréal ayant comme
langue maternelle l'anglais
en 2011 ils étaient 160 9 millions
mais selon les projections entre 2011 et
2030 6 la proportion de gens dont la
langue parlée à la maison et l'anglais
devrait passer de 4,1 pour cent à 5,1
pour cent
cela dit des enjeux dans certaines
régions du québec en
abitibi-témiscamingue à québec en
mauricie les anglophones aurait de la
difficulté à obtenir des soins de santé
dans leur langue
dans le bas saint laurent pour tout le
territoire il n'y a qu'une école qui
offre les cours primaire et secondaire
en anglais et les thèmes métis beach
ensuite les jeunes doivent partir de la
région s'ils veulent poursuivre leur
éducation en anglais
le gouvernement du québec reçoit des
sommes du fédéral pour les minorités
linguistiques
ils se demandent donc si cet argent ne
devrait pas être utilisé davantage dans
ces régions si vous voulez qu'on vérifie
quelque chose
écrivez nous